hi i'm sophie i'm pablo
and this is our project night hunter
so
um
our early concept for this game was
something like in invisible maze that
you could only hear
so we had the idea of sort of trying to
our the original idea came from the idea
of um
superheroes who have like enhanced
senses since this was to be an audio
only game we thought how can we sort of
enhance your hearing we thought what if
you could hear the things that you can't
see
so the idea was that you would try to
move through a maze you would hear
what
you would use something like sonar to
try to um like you'd send out a wave it
would make a sound you could tell where
it was in space and avoid it
that's pretty hard as it turns out one
of the things we wanted to explore by
making this game was how good at people
or how good are people at actually
figuring out where that invisible thing
is
turns out the answer is not very good if
you're trying to avoid something that's
very important that you are very good
because you can't tell where the edges
are you can just kind of tell it's
vaguely over there
so
yeah our original when we did original
um
play storming sort of um
playing around with physical objects to
come up with a concept our original
concept uh we we split two tables up
and we put objects down to represent
sound sources and we and we had people
walk through it and when they got close
to sound source we were kind of ping and
that was like our original ideating sort
of play test
um
but after that we transitioned into
um more of a collection kind of game
because
it's hard to detect those edges
and so with our with our fit our first
physical play test we had one player
wearing blackout glasses
um
so they were effectively blind and then
a bunch of our play testing um
helpers who are in this room
um would act as sound sources that the
player is trying to collect and so um
they would
move opposite the direction where the
player is facing so it's as though
they're
always moving forward relative to all
the other people
and all the sound sources would each um
take a step in cadence and then make
some sort of sound like we did clapping
at first
but we
we had a lot of actually very important
findings just from this first play test
yeah um one of the things we found out
is that if everyone is making the same
sound at the same time it's really
really hard to figure out where they're
coming from it's just one big cloud of
what the heck is going on
um and it was also pretty hard to try to
even like we had to show people how to
move at first it was hard to understand
just from a um description like if he's
looking at me
i'm going this way
and um we had to have someone pointing
which way the person was looking yeah so
we tried a second round where the um
where everyone was making a different
noise and they weren't moving in sync
and it proved really helpful for our
play tester who could lock on to one
sound turn toward it until they got
close enough when the person got close
enough tapped on the shoulder they were
out collected basically and they got
slowly faster and faster just locking
onto that one individual sound pointing
towards it
collecting it until they were all out we
had a timer for that second round the
timer was not necessary
so we're like wait yay this works so
much better
so we moved on to making a unity
prototype yeah so our original unity
prototype was kind of like this it was
it was a sort of a duplication of this
where
uh the frames were in the center of the
screen and then there was kind of a
cloud of sound sources around them and
they would move against where the player
was looking so
again it was like they were flying
around trying to collect
these sound sources but um
we quickly found out that it was
like um the other team mentioned is that
it's very hard to determine
or to
to lock onto something when you can
when
there's like
variance on the z-axis when you can
look up and down so we flattened it
so they were all around you but even
then it was still hard pretty hard to
focus on each individual sound yeah so
we decided to change to
sort of an endless runner prototype
where the idea is that you're here
things are constantly coming at you and
you have to turn your head so that they
will move toward you it's like there's
something coming over here oh i can hear
that up now it's coming at me collected
huzzah
so you transition to a
linear experience yeah
so our final product is night hunter the
idea is that it's a little hard to see
in this particular photo but you're this
tiny little
um
arrow ship thing
and there are small sound sources that
you can hear they're headed toward you
and you have to turn your head wearing
the frames
to find them they will if you are
looking at it it will move towards you
if um
if you miss it it hits a invisible plane
behind you and is deleted and another
one spawns because another thing we
found was if there are multiple you will
hear one over here and one over here and
you can't tell which is which even if
the sounds are different it's still
really hard it's easier if the sounds
are different it's still really hard
yeah and another massive change
we made is that there is a ui now yeah
so before we were just doing completely
blind you're just
you're only using your ears to play but
um
we actually made this ui for
um play testing initially or for
debugging so that we could see the
sounds
coming at the player but we thought
you know maybe for a tutorial this would
be really useful because then the player
could kind of conceptualize what they're
doing before they go blind
but
we decided to actually add it into the
game so
uh you you can always see where you are
and you can see the sounds coming into
view they they start out of you so you
still have to use your ears to localize
it
but once you get close enough to it you
can see it and then with more precision
you can
actually collect it instead of having a
full range of vision and sight it's more
like you have a really really limited
range of vision it's like being
almost blind
um because this is like you still have
to get yourself in the
general area using your um auditory
senses and then you can see it and then
that helps with the final like oh it's
right here i thought it was here-ish oh
i can turn it i can see it now it's
there yeah and with this version of the
game um we felt like
now it was sort of
we didn't want players to rely too much
on their visuals we still wanted to get
that audio first gaming experience so
what we decided to do is have the screen
occasionally go black so you can't see
anything and then you have to truly rely
on just your ears to actually collect
the sounds so you'll be playing for a
while and some of these screens black
and you're like ah what's happening wait
i can still hear things it must still be
going no oh i still have to use my ears
and we kind of rationalize that as like
a radar system failure so like you're on
this spaceship and you have a radar
of like the your immediate surroundings
and then occasionally
for whatever technical reasons it goes
black and then you're flying blind but
you can still use your other sensors aka
your ears to navigate